wesley is proven to be extremely solid
though so it won't be easy
it seemed as if magnus was still
thinking which opening to choose
not a very motivated handshake there
like do we really have to start already
he does go for d4
and we get a sloth
magnus normally doesn't enter the
complications with knight c3 dc4
or e6 plays a slow line e3 bishop g4
that typically leads to white having the
two bishops while black has a rock-solid
structure
knight h4 is working on that project
he's trying to catch this bishop and it
is all
highly theoretical territory both these
guys
look bored executing the opening moves
it's all theory bishop g2
one of the main moves here g5 is a very
typical
way to handle this structure because you
don't want to run into white going g5
gaining space here so you fix this
and then you try to deploy your pieces
knight bd7
sometimes you castle by hand go king of
8 g6 king g7
sometimes you go for dc4 followed by
knight d5 it's
not easy to gain an advantage here but
magnus carlsen has something he normally
enjoys the two bishops and a board full
of pieces
so he can play slowly and try to build
on that
he castles kingside which i'm not sure
yeah after going bishop t2 that's
probably what you do but
very often in these lines you see white
going for bishop d2 and long castles
wesley so still seems to be in book
doesn't really hesitate about any of his
moves
yeah he hasn't used almost any time
wesley so still has more than five
minutes
with the two second increment they he
managed to build up some time thereby
magnus carson has
used at least half a minute one final
thing about this line that you normally
have this mexican standoff here between
the
two queens neither side wants to capture
because queen b3 a b improves white
structure
while queen takes b6
both a b and knight takes b6 and 10
total black after knight takes b6 white
is forced to break the tension here
which he doesn't really want to
and a b gets the rook into play so
typically neither side is gonna take and
we see wesley now
avoiding the queen exchange actively by
going queen to c7
this is preparing another typical move
knight to b6 forcing whites to
reveal what he wants to do with this
tension because cd5
even ed5 normally this cleric
clarification helps black
well if white goes c5 this would be nice
if he had time to build up an attack
here but normally he's too slow and
black gets counter player with either e5
or b6
it's a pretty standard stuff it looks as
if he would be looking at the white king
but i believe that knight takes g4 never
works it's only a check on h2
the g2 bishop will defend the white king
very
well so that's just something to check
but it doesn't work
no magnus has to decide if you yeah e4
knight takes e4 is on the board knight
takes e4 d
takes e4 and after bishop takes this
position is opening up for the pair of
bishops
yeah carlson won a very similar
structure against nakamura in london a
while back where he
didn't get much out of the opening but
then later managed to simplify position
by going d5 and exploit his pair of
bishops
but in general this structure is
supposed to be extremely solid for black
so still a lot of work
for the world champion to make something
happen yes to worry about his
a3 pawn so he retreats his bishop also
preparing d5 without having to
be concerned about knight to c5
[Music]
not so clear to me how blackshare
arranges pieces would be nice to have
time to bring the knight
to either h4 or f4 but if you start this
journey you have to be
very very sure the opening of the center
does not
kill you long before the knight arrives
on h4 it might kill you it seems to be
fast
d5 is in the air so he castles king side
instead of knight f8
yeah he gets this king out of the way
which is sensible but now of course
where he's long way
from getting this knight to its best
square and
feels like magnus with this very timely
e4 has managed to create a bit of an
initiative
still i hesitate to say he's better
because i'm not sure
how realistic it is to break through in
the center here
but it's a little harder for black to
maneuver you got to keep an eye on the
g5 pawn else such maneuver would be nice
but i don't know how to implement that
it's not obvious where this knight is
going on b6 it can always be bothered
with a4 a5
so wesley correctly decides to wait go
rookie eight
and while magnus probably is not not in
a hurry that's gonna build his position
up for the rook on c1
yeah that's what happened tiny advantage
for magnus carlsen
but there is still everything to play
for
the kind of position he loves playing so
i'm sure that he is happy
with what he achieved and he will try to
improve his position
move by move this is a slow position but
with space advantage and pair of bishops
this is looking promising for magnus
carson
yeah wesley would like to go by show f6
knight f8 knight g6 all these moves but
the reason is calculating is that
after bishop f6 or after animal frankly
you have to
make sure that d5 does not hurt you and
here it does seem like a problem because
cdcd the queen
is under attack and both bishops are
breaking free
not sure how wesley should react to that
maybe has to go queen
b6 back off for the exchange of queens
probably magnus would be the one to turn
it down now by going something like
queen c2
not an easy to position to play and it
tells on the clock where wesley after
blitzing out the opening is now down to
two minutes has to come up with a plan
here
not an easy thing
it feels like you should be waiting for
white's right to do something because
with black
it is really you shouldn't go for moves
like
e5 or c5 at least not in this position
yeah c5 the b7 pawn is a problem and e5
just
seems to open the position up for the
white bishops as well exactly that's
what he does
for black he goes for queen b6
and i said magnus should avoid the
exchange of queens here let's say
if see if he agrees with that doesn't
seem like it he doesn't mind it he wants
to go for the opening of the position
with t5 instantly
[Music]
what does wesley do
the problem is if you go for this cd
cd once again the white pieces are fully
activating you're not in time to
get in the move like bishop c5 which i
would really like to play
or if you do it instantly c6 is dropping
so it does look like
problems also if you go edc dc5 trying
to do
this your idea he's in trouble he
probably has to go
c takes d5 and try to defend this but
unless too many targets bishop a7 might
even be a move immediately but also rook
takes d5 and turning rook c7 or bishop
takes d5
c6 d5 on the board he's going for a
position you are talking about but so
many options
for a pair of bishop this is a paradise
he can play for
on both flanks thanks to having these
powerful bishops
yeah i'm glad it's magnus's decision
because
every candidate move that i pointed out
makes a lot of sense to me rook c7 rook
d5 bishop d5 bishop a7
he goes for rook d5 probably that's the
one you have to calculate at least you
just keep your initiative
planning rook c7 also hinting and you
might just take the pawn
also on a7 you can grab a bomb bishop
the a7
could be a threat as well so many things
in the air not easy for wesley so to
hold the position yeah i believe it
might be
beyond repair already and magnus here
superior understanding bishop f6 is a
good move targeting
where rook c7 looks terribly strong for
example
when all these guys are falling and if
white can keep one of his b pawns
bishop takes a7
pointers but should be two rook d1 with
very unpleasant pin
bishop a7 you have to make sure b6
doesn't hurt you
but it does not seem to be the case here
just rook d1 anyway
lastly play knight e5 but this is just a
pawn down
it is desperation of course he's going
to try to put up a fight but magnus has
many ways to
roam this could already be one of them
if i'm not blundering
no i don't think i am because rook d7
you want to play
i'm wondering i wanted to give a check
and another check
she's six it might work that should be
good enough
yeah i think he's going for it now it's
two pawns up for the world champion
that would be pawns but still one one is
enough
of them to promote it with the help of
the pair of bishops it shouldn't be
difficult
yeah very smooth positional victory by
magnus carlsen
that's what he does it makes his things
look almost effortless
i'm not quite sure where things went
wrong for wesley have a feeling queen c7
might have been too optimistic and after
e4 magnus
managed to consolidate his pair of
bishops in the meantime vichyanan drew
against
lebaneronian that means that aronian has
now 14 and a half and rishi as well on
14 and a half they are sharing
third place yeah
they if wesley loses he joins them or no
he's half a point ahead he's still half
a point ahead of them
but many games left this is round eight
today
we will have one more game today and
tomorrow nine more rounds of blitz chess
what happened here he played knight d3
and magnus decided
a small surprise against rook c8 decided
it's not necessary
just went rogue d1 pinning this knight
so bishop b2 is impossible
and wesley goes knight b4 which allows
white to keep both his extra pawns after
takes takes
bishop t4 for example intending bishop
c3
yeah this is a walk in the park for the
world champion two bishops two extra
pawns
by the problem it seems that caravana's
bad day
is continuing vladimir kramnik has
quite a lot of an advantage against him
in this round god's place bishop e4
same story just restricting this knight
on b4 can't jump here or there
wesley is going to go wish for f6 bishop
c5 and that
resigned so magnus carson
increases his lead to